would you just be down to leak that [ __ ]
I'll be obviously not you but like an
anonymous DJ man I don't I don't know
that sound incriminating bro I don't
know about that I missed the days we
used to just get random like songs
leaked with like hella [ __ ] random
like websites drops all over them I mean
that [ __ ] scared me bro
they didn't got my [ __ ] bro what else
they got like
[ __ ] burn the iCloud have you ever had
anyone leak any of your [ __ ] yeah bro
they they leaked uh
some [ __ ] one of the songs that's on the
side we got leaked but it's cool [ __ ]
it's fine I'm like that [ __ ] so far so
how does how do you think that happens
because nowadays people text songs so
often I'm not gonna say how I think it
happened I tell you to the side because
if I tell you how I think it happened a
[ __ ] might not have thought like that
and be like oh okay I think like it
happens a lot because people will record
at Studios and then when they leave they
just leave the session and their [ __ ] on
a car that's what I was gonna say why
you tell them why you getting them game
bro nah that's what I was gonna say bro
look I have a recording studio we're
sitting in my studio now you know how
many artists have recorded like
I mean I've had like major artists
record here yeah and then nine months
later their team reaches out and be like
hey could we get our sessions from last
year and I'm like y'all didn't take them
nine months ago but obviously I give it
to him but it's like the fact that like
I like this dude's half of this dude's
album has been sitting on my [ __ ]
computer thank God it's me who had it
but like you know some of these Studios
people be working in are [ __ ] weird
yeah Engineers have weird interns
whoever okay got deleted doesn't even
worse that's worse cause what if the
[ __ ] what if what if you're depending
on my computer not to crash and me to
have a backup just get your files bro if
you just get your files just get up out
of here with the fast bro that's the
main way that [ __ ] happened bro 100
[ __ ] you tweaking at the studio
[ __ ] a new intern he said we
sweeping to one in the morning just to
get that file buddy like I'm sweeping
this same spot to this [ __ ] leave